So,
uh,
we're now at the stage
where we're considering the
implications of uncertainty.
So I hope that the subtlety and surprise
element of the class will gradually
pick up, uh, without
increasing the difficulty.
The complexity will pick up a little bit,
but not the difficulty.
It's just you have to keep a
few more things in your head,
but the mathematics isn't any harder.
So we started,
we ended last time talking about default
and inferring default probabilities.
And so I just want to
finish off that discussion.
So suppose that at any stage of the tree,
you know,
lots of things can happen in the world.
We're always going to model the
uncertainty in the future by a tree with
different things happening.
And at each of these nodes people
are going to have a discount rate.
So maybe it'll be a, you know, uh,
r equals 20% and here are could equal 15%,
something like that.
And we want to add to this the
possibility that there's the fault.
So if we add the possibility of default,
you know,
on these things keep going and maybe
their payoffs at the end or pay offs along
the way.
If at any point in the tree like this one,
we add a new possibility,
which is the default possibility.
Okay?
And we assume, so this just
happens by when new people to fall,
they never default before
they have to make a payment.
So when do they default exactly when
they're supposed to make a payment.
So suppose that this guy is going to
default here when he's going to make a
payment. You know what every possible
scenario he would default there.
So you've got a very simple
uh, model of default. Okay?
So not a very realistic one where the
guy defaults in all of these following
scenarios. Okay? So some things
just bad once he's gotten here,
you know that he's not going to
make the payment the next period.
And let's suppose we further
assume that only does it,
not only does he default there,
but he defaults on everything thereafter.
So the payoff is just going to be
zero here. So this is going to be,
originally we had probabilities,
p one p two p three,
let's say for the probabilities.
Now we're going to have probabilities d
for default and then one minus d times
all of these,
right?
So essentially what have we done?
We've simply replaced in our calculation
of payoffs and present values,
we've simply replaced these possibilities
with probability p one p two p three
we added another possibility,
but the payoffs are zero here.
Nothing's going to happen
from then on except zero.
And we said that happened
with probability,
which means presumably all of these
have to be scaled down by that.
So they still add up to one.
So essentially the point I'm
trying to make is that default,
uh, that, uh, leads who
zero payoffs thereafter
after is just
like
discounting more.
Why is that?
Because whatever calculation you did for
the value here of what the bond could
possibly be worth there is,
it's all the same numbers
as they were before,
except we've multiplied it by one
minus d. Okay. So it's the same thing.
So instead of going one over one plus
r times, you know, future payoffs,
that's no default value.
Hmm.
Okay. Now, so that time, suture payoffs,
now we've got the fault value
under this special kind of the fall
is going to be one minus d times one
over one plus r times the same future
payoffs.
Okay.
But always could make one.
I could rewrite one minus D as
one over one plus s or something.
And so then I really have just one over
one plus r times one over one plus s.
So that's just one over
one plus r Plus s plus s.
So that's going to equal one over one
plus r Plus s plus r s times future
values.
Okay, so the effect of this
special kind of default,
we just get zero thereafter. You know,
the guy decides after this payment,
I'm not gonna make any more payments
on DePaul. The faulting from then on.
That's the same thing when
valuing the future payoffs.
It's the same thing as instead of
discounting by our discounting by r plus s
with a little bit. Our Times, as
you know, if rns are small numbers,
this is probably quite a small number.
So default probabilities get mapped
into spreads that are called.
Okay.
The Way to evaluate it is just you
just multiply it by one minus D,
which is the same thing as
discounting by a higher number.
And that a higher number
is almost the same.
It's very close to r plus
d as a matter of fact,
because one minus D is one of
one plus ass. If d is very small,
s is going to be very close to d as well.
Okay.
Okay, so on Uproxx. Okay, so,
okay, so that, okay, so what's
the implication of this,
the implication of this in a special case,
special case,
again, where are we? We don't have,
we just have, you know, no one
certainty except we have default.
So here or there could be d one one minus
d one and here there could be probably
living to fall two on one minus t two
probability of default three one minus d
three and we've got interest
rates are zero. So this will be,
um,
I zero I f one F two.
Okay. So if you knew what the
interest rate was going to be today,
you knew what the interest
rate was going to be tomorrow.
You knew what the interest rate was
going to be the day after tomorrow.
There no uncertainty about interest rates,
they're perfectly anticipated will,
but you know that there's a probability
of default each time. So in Stage one,
this guy might default before
making his payment here,
which case you're just going to get
zero. In Stage two, he might default,
instead of making this payment, won't
pay the coupon, he'll just default.
Or in year three he might default.
Okay.
So what's the implication
of what we just said? Um,
you can evaluate this bond.
The payoffs are the bond.
So let's say it pays off
coupon, c c a hundred plus city. Okay.
All right.
The way you would evaluate that without
the fault is you would just take
the value of the coupon.
The present value would have been one,
um, would have been, uh, you
would have done it recursively,
you would have gotten,
you know,
p three equals a hundred plus c,
then you would have said p two, it
would've gone. And your computer,
you're going to said p two is one over
one plus I f two times a hundred plus c.
Okay.
And then p won equals.
So the value here is the hundred plus
c discounted by that Ford, right?
Then [inaudible] would have been c
plus p two divided by one plus I f one.
So you take the value here, time to that.
So this is in case there's no default,
and p zero would have been c plus
p one over one plus I f zero.
All right? So that's how you would
have done it by backward induction.
But now that you know,
chances, there's default. You have to,
you have to not multiply by one.
Plus I have to,
you have to multiply all the sides
things by the probability of default.
You'd have to multiply this by,
if we change colors by one minus d,
You'd have to multiply this by one minus
d two and you'd have to multiply this
by one minus d one times one
minus d two and this by one minus,
uh, sorry, this would
be one minus d three.
This is one minus d three times d two
and this is one minus d one times one
minus d two friends,
one minus d three.
Okay.
So this value would be the old value
got here multiplied by one minus d three
multiplied by this one,
minus d three.
This value is what you would've gotten
here, but you've already scaled it down.
So multiplied by one minus dean too.
And this is why one minus t one.
So what's the upshot?
The upshot is had you.
And so then this is okay. So that gives
you the price, uh, with the fault.
Okay.
So
Yup.
Well I could have done it two ways.
I could have written.
So what you're suggesting is a better
way would have been to say p two the
default,
the default fine p two is going to
be one minus d three times p three
okay. Which is also equal to p three
because there's no default after here,
the world just sends than p one is equal
to one minus d two times p two okay.
But that P to remember is already one
minus d three times a p three okay.
And then p zero
is going to be one minus d one times
one minus d two times p one but that's
equal to
one minus d one times one minus d two
times p one which is one minus the three
times p three
right?
Sorry. If you go from here to here,
the value here is a hundred plus c.
So if p three is just a hundred plus C,
that's leave it as 100 plus c
that's what the guy actually pays.
Okay.
So the present value would just be um oh.
Then you have to divide
all this by one plus I to,
sorry,
this is one plus I f two all making
a mess of this and this is a,
okay, so usually you'll go back
from here to here discounting by
the interest rate.
Okay?
But now we're going to have
to also multiply by the
probability that you default
to go back here.
So we get a lower number.
P two is not just a 100 plus c divided
by one plus I f that's the discounting.
You also have to multiply by
the probability of default.
Then when you go back one period further,
you have to discount again. Okay?
So I should have multiple divided this
by one plus I f one you have to discount
it and also you have to multiply it
by the probability of default. Okay?
But the thing you're,
you're bringing backwards is p two
which has already taken to account the
probability of default the next time.
Okay?
And then when you go
back one step further,
you have to do the whole thing
again divided by one plus I f zero.
Okay.
I have one minus. This is p
one, not p two. So I have a,
okay.
No. Okay. So, but I'm switching the,
the peas on you. I've got a pee. Okay.
So when you have p when we go from here.
Okay.
You can, the value here, we just
calculated it was going to be p two. Okay.
So here,
the value of p one taking into account
the fault is one minus d two times p two.
Okay. Which already takes into
account that the fault next time. Um,
yeah,
thanks P to discounted by
the interest rate here.
So I've got the one minus d two here
now and I discount back to here.
You're saying how come the [inaudible]
showing up anymore? Cause I'm,
I'm just at the one that's your question.
Right. Okay. So it doesn't show up.
It's just a p zero is one minus
Dijuan oh you're asking this,
you're right.
One minus steam on you are
right times p one divided by
one plus I f zero.
That's right.
But if I plug in for p
one p one already had,
that's where the dean too came from.
So p ones got the deed to it.
So it's one minus d one times one minus
t two times p two and then p two had a p
three or it. So I've got all the
defaults in it. Are you with me now?
So sorry about that. So you're
right, I said it wrong. So, okay, so,
but this is the point. This is Jay.
This was supposed to be obvious.
I didn't even think about it.
What I'm the next step is the
thing that's not obvious. Okay.
So to discount, you just figure
the here the potential cash flows,
you're discounting them
by the interest rate.
You also have to discount it again by
the fact that the guy might actually pay
you.
So that gives you a lower present value.
Pink to yellow p two is less than the,
no default,
quite p too.
When you discount again,
you're discounting the yellow
pea to by the interest rate here.
And also the fact that
the guy might not pay.
So you have to disk multiplied by one
minus t two and also the fact that he
might not pay the the
the forward. Right. Okay.
And You keep moving that backwards.
Okay. So that was supposed to be obvious.
Even though I made it sound complicated,
what slightly subtler is just
saying the same thing backwards,
which is suppose that I,
um,
saying the same thing backwards is
suppose I knew all these forward rate
suppose.
Okay.
I knew the forward rate.
Suppose,
suppose I,
uh,
suppose I had a bunch of bonds.
So polls,
I had American bonds,
bonds, um, coupon bonds.
Okay. And so the American coupon
bonds are going to, are, you know,
they're going to pay,
you know,
the one year pays a coupon c one and
has a face of a hundred and has a price
high one.
The two year American bond has a coupon
seed to a face of a hundred and a price
of Pi two.
And let's say the five year has some
things see five phase of a hundred and the
price pie five. Okay. Now from
that we know that we can deduce,
you know what all the forwards are.
We did that in the first class.
Okay. So now suppose at the
same time we have Argentina,
were there many Argentine sovereign
bonds promise payments and dollars by the
way, they're trying to
trade them internationally.
So let's say Argentina,
we also have the Argentina bonds.
See Hat one a hundred pie hat one that's
the one year down to the five year,
which is the Argentina see had five a
hundred and p hat five by had five it's
price.
Now let's suppose that um,
Argentina could default
whereas America can't.
So it's quite likely that pie one will
be less than the American pie one and pie
five is going to be less than the
American pie five because all these bonds
might default. So if the coupons were the
same, if you see one hat was the saying,
the c one and c five hat
was the same as [inaudible],
the fact that Argentina could default
obviously would mean it's bonds would
trade less for the American ones.
So the question is,
can you figure out the
default probabilities very
quickly in Argentina without
having to do a lot of
complicated calculations?
Well one thing you could do one
thing and the answer is yes.
And why is that? Because you could
take this data and you could say,
so we can just erase this here.
We could say assuming
no default,
um,
we could explain these prices.
Okay.
These prices by finding,
just like we did in America,
the Argentine Argentine forwards.
Okay.
Forwards one plus I hat zero one plus
I hat forward one and one plus I hat
forward for.
Okay,
so these are the Argentine forwards.
Now these four words would be much
bigger than the American forwards.
Why is that? Because the prices
in Argentina are so much lower.
If you're assuming there's no default
assuming no default contrary to fact,
how could you explain all these very
low prices where you must think that in
Argentina they've got very high
interest rates and very high forwards.
So the discounting more and that's why
they've got lower prices and we know how
to get those forwards.
Assuming there was no default.
So the trick I'm merely pointing out
now is that if we now go back and say,
Aha, Argentina doesn't have different
Ford's because anyone in Argentina,
the bonds are denominated in dollars
precisely so that people can be crossover
investors and American can put his money
in Argentina or an Argentine can put
his money in America. So you can
move your money to either place.
So it must be that the forward
rates can't be different.
If you knew for sure you're
going to get paid in Argentina,
you'd have to have the
same Ford rates in America.
So the reason these forward rates are
higher is because there's a chance of
default.
So what is the chance of default?
So I claim the chance of default is,
and I was supposedly,
you're supposed to realize this now,
if I'd been clear before
you would have gotten it,
he would see where I'm going.
The chance of default is
incredibly simple to find out.
So it's one minus d a t
equals what?
Okay. But in terms of Ford's
is what? It's not pie.
This pie, this isn't the zero price.
This is the big price of the bond.
So it's not pie hat t over piety.
What is it though?
So,
okay, this is going to be
a bigger number than that.
And the fact that ratio is
the default probability.
Okay,
so,
so this is assuming,
remember that if the Argentine
bonds defaults at this period,
say it's never going to
pay anything after that,
you're going to get zero
payoff and all the other barns,
Argentine bonds will also default. I
claim that this is going to be the, uh,
this is the easy way of getting
the default probability.
And so the differences in the forwards
is just explain by the default
probabilities.
And so the extra Argentine interest,
if this is a higher number than that,
you know,
this is approximately one minus d is
approximately one over one plus the,
which is, and so it's basically, you know,
this is very close to that.
Basically if d,
if all the numbers are
IMB or small than I,
F t minus one is
approximately I f t minus one,
the American one plus this
default rate in Argentina. Okay.
So I should probably have a hat because
what I'm referring to Argentina with the
hat.
Okay.
All right. So why is that
true? I just argued and how
could that possibly be true?
Okay. The week. Okay.
So you see what I'm claiming that you
have now a very simple algorithm for
finding out, inferring what Argentina
default rates are. You can just,
again, I'm making a special assumption
that when Argentina defaults,
you get nothing.
That really isn't the case.
There's some huge convention that happens
in all the countries get together.
They defaulted on,
they've got some big meeting and you know,
someone like Brady invents some idea will,
they'll old less than there'll be a
writing down of principle by the way.
So whenever this happens,
there is recovery is recovery,
uh, after, uh, writing down of principal.
Okay? So what all the
countries do as they say, okay,
we know you can't pay all that you owe us,
we'll settle for half of it.
We'll write down the principle and we'll
hold you to that half or to a third of
it.
Okay.
And so this is one of the
things we curiously haven't
done in America where all
these homeowners can't pay and we
don't write down their principle.
We just throw them out of their houses.
But anyway,
let's say you wrote the principle
down to zero and that special case,
you could easily infer from the price
of the Argentine bonds what the default
probabilities were and by this formula.
And so the question is why is that true?
Okay? We know how to calculate
the forwards and America
given the American data.
That was one of the first
things we did in class.
We said that every American company in
the whole country financial company is
doing that. Everybody has those
four words calculated. Okay? Now,
if you give them the Argentine data,
which is after all just coupons
and the prices of the bonds,
you could find Argentine forwards
assuming there's no default.
But that of course, but, but, but there
is the fault. So it must be that they,
there are, they have access to the
American interest rates and forwards.
But the Argentine mine bond might default.
But you see what we did when
we did this calculation,
the difference between the backward
induction in America from here to here was
just discounting by the American forward.
Okay.
To go to Argentina,
we had to discount by the American
Ford and multiplied by one minus d.
So discounting it again.
So all I'm saying is that in the u s one,
we went backwards.
We just discounted by
this thing in Argentina,
when you go backwards, you have
to discount, buy this thing.
Okay?
So those things have to be the same.
Okay? So the Argentinian discount
is like taking the, uh, um,
I hope I haven't got the thing,
see,
the American Ford's is going to
be less than the Argentine Ford's.
It's going to be like that.
Okay?
Okay. So that's it.
There's nothing to, uh,
else to show except that whenever
you're going backwards here,
you're discounting. Remember
you're discounting by the,
uh, you know, the, the,
the interest rate times the probability
that you're actually going to pay off.
And so that's what it is in a Argentina.
Um,
hang on.
Hope have an inverted one of these.
Uh,
okay.
Yeah,
exactly.
So if you write one minus d times the
American thing in the denominator.
So as I said to to, to do the disc
carrying in Argentina at every step,
going back from here to here,
what did we do in Argentina?
We simply took one minus d that was
the default rate hat in Argentina and
discounting it at the American forward.
Okay? So that's what I did here.
So if I take one minus d hat,
you know,
multiplied by one.
So I take one minus t hat
multiplied by one over this. Okay?
I just get one over the Argentine
discount and that's how we calculated.
That's how we went backwards with our
recursion. Just taking the interest rate,
the discount one over one plus I times
one minus d and that's how we discounted
going backwards.
And so therefore in Argentina,
if you're forgetting that there's default
and you're just thinking you have to
discount at the right rate and
you're getting this discount,
you're getting this number.
But in reality you should have
been taking this divided by that.
So therefore figuring out this and knowing
that tells you what this has to be.
So it's extremely simple to
deduce what the market thinks.
Argentinian default
probabilities are year by year.
If you make the ad to the
assumption that once they default,
they default completely.
And if you think you're only
going to get a little bit back,
well then the calculation won't
change that much. Okay. Yeah.
Yeah. So you could also do it
by using the price of Zeros,
but to me the best thing is the,
the easiest thing is using the forwards,
but you can also do it by zero. Okay. So
that's all I wanted to say. All right,
so and, and, and as I said,
the one last thing to say is that
if these numbers are all small,
then one minus one over one minus D or
one minus d one minus D is approximately
equal to one over one plus d.
Okay.
That's if d is very small, those are
practically the same things. And then,
you know, if you multiply one over
one plus d by One over one plus I,
it's almost one over one plus d plus Psi.
So it's almost this thing,
it's not quite true,
literally true.
But it's very close to say that the
gap between Argentinian forwards and
American Fords is just
the default probability in
Argentina and that that reason
is why it's called a default spread.
Okay.
You just add some spread to the
interest rate and you've pretty even,
so you can guess by the spread
what the probability of default is.
If it's a 6% interest
there and a 3% interest,
you know if the 8% interest
there in 3% interest here,
somebody must think the probability
of default is 5% there. That's it.
Okay,
so let's now move to a tree
where you have to make decisions.
So I'm going to now describe the
method of backward induction,
which occurs over and over and over again.
And we've used it a couple times,
but not in its subtlest form.
So backward induction,
a backward induction.
Okay. Now who first invented the
idea of backward induction? Well,
the first person who spelled
it out formally was Armello
who's a in 1910 I think
that's within a couple of years,
a famous mathematician
Frankel's or mallow axioms.
And he proved that chess,
that there is an optimal strategy.
There is an optimal strategy
strategy in chess by backward induction.
Okay? So for example, let's take a game.
So we always are on a tree,
but now we're going to use a slightly
extended definition of a tree.
A tree is going to look
like this, you know, there.
So it's a root finite number
of branches from every,
I want to formally define a tree. You
know what it sort of looks like. Okay.
And there's no reason why the number of
branches has to be two or even has to be
the same from every point. But the
reason we're going to extend it is the,
the node is going to be described,
is going to describe by who moves.
So let's say white is moving here
and black is moving here. You know,
let's say the outcomes
are a win for white.
I win for black,
a draw or a draw.
Okay, so the question is, so
it's a to move chess game,
white moves first up or down. Then after
white moves, black moves up or down,
and then the gay man's,
and depending on where position you reach,
either it's a win for wide, a
win, win for black or a draw.
So what should white do?
Assuming that black is a smart player,
what should she do
so clearly?
Um, so what did Zur mellow do? He said,
not only there's an optimal strategy,
but you know what the outcomes
should be with rational players.
So as [inaudible] said,
if white goes up, okay,
then black is clearly going
to go down and win the game.
So white ought to be thinking here,
if I go up the game of it won't end
for another period. It's already lost.
So the value of the game is already zero.
Okay?
So this method of backward
induction attaches the value here.
We have values at the end,
okay?
And so to figure out what the right
thing to do is buy backward induction,
you can propagate the values backwards.
If black makes the right choice here,
but you know the, the payoff is
black gets the negative of white.
So the right choices here are a black
could get negative one or could get zero.
So black clearly wants to get zero. So
black could win the game by moving down.
So black,
surely we'll move down.
So I should think of the game is already
lost here and pretend that I had a
shorter tree with the final valuation
of zero at this node. Similarly,
if white goes down, it doesn't
matter what black does, uh,
the game is going to be drawn.
So quite should think to himself,
the game is already a draw. If I go
down and now white has an easy choice,
do I want to move to a loss or do I want
to move to a draw so clearly white so I
could,
I could just pick a move for black year.
Clearly white is going to go down
and therefore with correct play,
the game is a draw. So by
backward induction, you
figure out the correct play.
Now why is this surprising?
Because chess has an incredibly big tree,
not an infinite tree. You know, there
are all these rules that keep it finite.
If you reached the same position
three times, it's considered a draw.
If you make something like 50 moves in
a row without upon moving, it's a draw.
Whatever those rules are. I used to play
chess quite a bit, I've even forgotten.
But whenever those rules are,
they're designed to make the game finite.
So the tree is finite and so it's
impossible to see the whole tree.
And how should you know
what to do at the beginning,
but you don't know what to
do at the beginning too.
You know what blacks going
to do afterwards and to
what could happen later in
the tree. But if you were fast enough
to put the whole thing on a computer,
you could figure out what to do at the
beginning because your best move at the
beginning depends on what you
think black is going to do next,
which depends on what he thinks
you're going to do after that,
which depends what you think he'll
do after that. But if the tree ends,
you can always go backwards from the end
to the beginning and figure out what to
do at the very beginning. Okay. So this
is a familiar argument to all of you.
I think it was a beautiful argument in,
um,
in chess in 1910 and then it
was anticipated, I mean, in,
in mathematics in 1910, the chess players
of course, all knew about it. So Stein,
it,
who was a world champion from when
to when something like 1870 or so,
two or 1880,
let's say to let's say 1921 to 1894,
I think it was,
world champion from then to their
Lasker became the champion then.
So he wrote a bunch of books and
stuff in which he said, you know,
there's a backward
induction value to chess,
but since we can't figure that
out on general principles,
you can tell by looking at
the configuration of pieces,
what the right possible move
is. And so you can, you can
have positional, you know,
you can have positional, uh, values.
So I'll do that. And then you can
have the backward induction values.
So for instance, a puddle positional
value might tell you that, uh, you know,
having a doubled ponds is a bad thing.
Having control of the center's a good
thing and you add up all those pluses and
minuses and you'd get these
positional values. And so, um,
he said your positional, you know, if
you've got the right positional, uh,
algorithm, right, positional
understanding, your positional
sense of what to do,
you only need to analyze one move deep.
You can figure out what the best
positions going to be and move that way.
And if we really understand the game
properly, that positional thinking,
that strategic thinking.
So let's call the strategic thinking is
going to give you the same decision as
the exhaustive analysis of all the
possibilities, which is tactical thinking.
Okay,
okay. So the two should
amount to the same thing.
Now in fact people can't do
the full tactical thing and
also they don't have the
full strategic understanding either.
So they kind of mixed strategy and
tactics and that's what makes the game
interesting.
So no one has ever written this,
but I'm sure there's an interesting
study to be made about what games are
interesting and they must be the
kinds of games where you can mix.
There's always a mixture of strategy.
And tactics in game theory as
we describe it and economics,
there's no such thing as strategy.
All of this is out.
It's all just backward induction,
which is what I'm teaching you. Um,
so the way computers play
chess incidentally is,
and the guy who invented this is Shannon.
Uh,
so he's a famous
mmm.
You know,
a famous professor of information systems.
So an engineering professor.
So he, he said, well, you
can't look at the whole tree,
which is too long in chess.
So what you should do.
So all of this extends way further.
Maybe you can only look to moves deep.
So what Shannon recommend is look as
far as you can put it in your computer,
apply some positional thinking to evaluate
these positions at the pseudo end of
the tree.
So it's really not a win for white,
let's just pretend white so far ahead
that we'll call it a win and a loss and a
draw on the draw.
You know,
that's just my looking at positional
values and then having a sign those
terminal nodes values.
Now by backward induction,
you can figure out what the value is here
and exactly what the right first move
to make is. And then after whites
move, black will come here.
Black can now look to moves deep.
So blacks going to look from
here all the way down here.
He's going to do is positional evaluator
to these nodes and try and figure out
what they're worth and then do backward
induction to figure out what his right
move is. Anyway, that's basically
the idea of all chess algorithms.
And then they've gotten refined by saying,
why don't we throw lots of refinements?
So I used to be very interested in this.
I don't think I'll talk more about it
unless anyone wants to ask me something.
So there's the origin of backward
inductions are mellows, uh,
proof and uh,
you know,
it's obviously a big deal in chess and
the chess players all knew about it
before as a Merrill low,
but they didn't write anything down.
His formulas are mellow.
So how does this apply to
everything we do in economics? Why?
I want to give a series of examples
culminating in market examples,
but starting off a little far from life.
So the first one I want to
give is the red and the black.
So then there's just two games. This is
the first one I invented 10 years ago,
but I don't think there's any way.
I think there they aren't that original.
I thought they were when I invented them.
But anyway, so the red and the black,
it works like this. There's
a deck of cards, 52 cards,
deck of 52 cards
and you can um,
someone offers you. So half
of them are 26 read, right?
And 26 black,
which is all I care about the cards and
someone offers you a game and they say,
okay, the decks upside
down, they've been shuffled.
You can turn over a
card and if it's black,
I'll pay you a dollar if it's red
and you have to pay me a dollar.
So I'm offering you this chance
to play this game. And of course,
um, you know, you can quit whenever you
want to. I can't keep forcing you to play.
So anytime you want to, you can
quit. So that's the game. Uh,
can stop
whenever you want.
Okay?
And once you drove a car and
you throw it away. And so I'm,
all these examples are going to
be examples of stopping games.
And you'll see an economics that,
you know,
when you prepay on a mortgage
or when you call a bond,
you're stopping the thing. The contract's
ending. I mean, your life is going on,
but that contract is ending.
So want to know when's the right time
to take an action like that. So red,
black is a simple game like that
where you turn over a card, you,
if it's black, you're in the black,
you win a dollar. If it's red,
you lose a dollar and you can stop
whenever you want. So you have an option.
So I call this an option
and most people totally
underestimate the value of options.
So let's just figure out how to
figure out the optimal thing to do.
What would you do in this game? Would you
play if I gave you the chance to play?
I think we did this on the very first
day. Yes. You're about to say something.
Your hand twitched. I thought, yeah,
I was going to say.
Okay, so we're, I'm not, I'm going
to now disagree with what you said,
but it's very interesting
what he said. He said, look,
if you draw a card at the beginning,
it's 50 50.
Whether you're going to win or not. If
you win, you get a dollar. If you lose,
you lose a dollar 50 50 chance.
You know,
if you're a little bit afraid of if a
full dollar loss is more important to you
than a dollar game, that's a bad, you
don't have that, that's the right away.
It's not very good. Uh, not very good
odds. I mean, it's barely even. Okay.
And if you're a little bit risk averse
and it's barely even, you shouldn't play.
Okay, but now is it really
barely even this game? Yep.
You should play it because even point
you might as well,
right? So you can't possibly
lose, if you play this right,
you can always go to the very end of
the deck. We're ignoring, you know,
good point.
We're ignoring your utility of time.
She can always go to the end of the
deck and assure yourself of zero.
So this is actually a pretty valuable
option to be able to stop. Like he says,
you can stop. Uh, if
the first one's black,
you could stop and then
you've won a dollar.
If the f a whole bunch of them are red
and you lose while you can always go to
the end of the deck and get zero so
you're never going to lose and you have a
chance of winning. So obviously you should
play. Even if you are risk averse, um,
you should play. And, but now the
question is, can we tell exactly?
Suppose your risk neutral,
how many dollars do you expect to win?
Okay.
Would you guess?
Yup.
You'd expect to get zero.
Okay.
Now he just made an argument that you
should expect more than zero because for
instance, he said, take this
strategy, pick a card. If it's black,
you went into all or quit. You're a
dollar. I had. So with 50% of the chime,
you're plus a dollar.
If it's red the first time,
just close your eyes and play to the
end of the game and you're going to get
zero because you're going to
win 26 times and lose 26 times.
So that's equal to 0.5.
So there's one strategy that
gets you 50 cents on average,
you can't lose and half the
time you'll get a dollar.
But that may not be the best strategy.
Yup.
Right. Okay. So he's saying, you
know, this is an ambitious enough,
this surely gets half a dollar,
but you could do much better.
Like let's just wait. You know, the
first time, suppose you get a dollar,
suppose you get black the first time.
So that gives you a dollar.
Now the trouble is the deck is starting
to turn against you now it's 25 blacks
in 26 reds.
So what would you do then?
You'd stop or keep going.
Okay,
well the, the, the deck is against you.
So now your very next draw is unfavorable.
And by the way,
playing till the end of the deck is going
to lose you a dollar because they're
25 black and 26 red.
So this argument that if you just
played at the end of the deck,
you'll break even.
It's not true after you've already taken
a black one out so you could lose it.
You know from that on, you're starting
to run a little bit of a risk.
So we're ignoring risk aversion,
we're just caring about expected dollars.
The fact is the deck is against you,
so should you play or not?
And so a first reaction is,
hell no, the Dex against me,
why should I draw another card?
But you still have the option
of going to the end of the deck.
So the most you could lose is a dollar.
If he went all the way to the
end of the deck. And who knows?
Maybe you'll get a run of more black
cards in the beginning and make a lot more
than a dollar. Okay, so you
should choose another card.
Okay. In which case if you get black
again, if you've got red on the next card,
you'd be breaking even.
But now it's 24 20 sorry,
25 25 and by the previous argument,
it's obvious you should pick another one
because the worst you can do is break
even from then.
But what if you got two blacks in a row?
Well now the deck is way against you.
It's 26 red and 24 black.
So your,
you know,
now you've only got a 48%
chance of drawing a black
when the next time the deck
is going further against you.
Should you really draw another black card?
It seems another card, it's, you
know, it's more likely to be read.
Well the answer is yes.
And suppose you got a black one again,
meaning your three up and
now the deck is 26 23 sorry,
I went the other way. 26 red, 23 black.
It's getting further and further against
you. Should you draw another card? Well,
what you've got is you've got
a bad deck working against you,
but you've got this option
or working in favor of you.
So the question is how valuable
is the option? And Mike,
I said people always underestimate
the value of options. And so,
okay,
go ahead.
Option A,
is there any loose condition is a either
bounced out or worse than your wind
conditions?
Yes.
But what is that condition?
13 months
you would take, you would, if
you got 10 blacks in a row,
you would keep drawing blacks.
Is that what you're saying?
Well, I mean at that point, if
you see that, that's awesome.
I'm assuming that you just pick another
red and then put up the end of the game.
You could lose, uh, would it be
13 more?
So you're saying you want to keep drawing
blacks until if you played till the
end of the deck, you would lose as
much as you'd want up until that point.
So you want are never run the risk of
losing money, of losing more. Okay.
Do you see that strategy would get
you to quit after the first one?
After the first black, if he ran to
the end of the day, uh, you know,
your strategy doesn't make sense.
You're always going to,
by going to the end of the deck,
you're always going to undo everything
you've won until that point because
you'll be zero no matter what.
If he'd go to the end of the deck,
yeah, she did. You quit.
Whenever you have more black cars,
their red card number of black cars
dec is less
number red.
Yes.
Whenever we do have one dog,
no,
that's it.
So he's saying just the
common sensical thing.
After you draw one black card,
he would quit because now
the deck is against you.
It's 25 red and only 25 black.
The dex against you.
Why go on and play against
an unfavorable deck.
You've got your dollar be satisfied
and quit. That's his recommendation.
But that's wrong. And it's because
you're doing what everybody does.
You underestimate the option.
The option is incredibly valuable here
and now I just want to show how to
compute what your optimal strategy
is and I think you'll be surprised.
Okay, you should keep drawing. Not three
times if he got a fourth black card.
Okay, so you've already made $4. It's a
sunk cost. You've got this horrible deck.
It's 26, 22. Should you keep
playing? Yes you should. Yes you can.
If you've got,
if you get a fifth black card in a row,
you're up $5.
The deck is horribly against you.
Should you keep playing? Yes,
you should. So anyway, um,
it's really shocking, I think. Okay,
so now let's just see how to compute
this out so that we don't have to argue
about it.
It's just a little bit of mathematics
and you just see how a surprising this
calculation is.
So how would you do it?
Okay, well, the key is to figure
out how to put it into a tree.
So I'm not going to draw a picture
because it gets too complicated,
but basically what you want
to know is how valuable.
Remember the tree in backward induction?
It was.
Take the thing at the end and then figure
out at the beach by propagating the
values backwards.
So if I have black and red here and I've
got one black card and no red cards,
the value to me of that is what
I'm going to win a dollar for sure.
If there's only one black card
left in the deck and no red cards,
I know I'm going to play to
the end and get a dollar.
And obviously the value of two black
cards, no red cards is $2 et cetera.
And I also know what's the
value to me of no black cards.
And one if I know that there are no black,
you know,
you know what every stage
what's left in the deck.
Cause you've seen what came up before.
So if they're,
if you're at the very end of the deck
with no black cards and one red card,
what's the value of that position to you?
Zero not minus one zero.
Why is that?
Because you're going to quit.
You're not going to play the value.
And that's the critical step
seeing that this is zero. Okay.
Someone said minus one that
difference between zero and minus one.
That's the whole heart of
the thing. So zero one, two,
the value of that is also zero.
You're just going to quit. Okay.
So what in general is the value?
What is the value of v if there
be black cards and our red cards?
What's the value to you?
Well,
crucial step is that you can
choose to quit by not playing.
So this is the value from
then on to you be, you know,
so be black cards left for red.
Our red cards left.
You could get zero by quitting.
Okay. Or You could draw a card.
Now what happens to
you if you draw a card?
What happens to you if you draw a card?
Well,
with probability be over being plus art.
You win a dollar,
right?
But then you move on to the new deck.
And so what do I write?
V here?
V of B minus one.
And are,
okay.
Okay.
But with probability are Overby.
Plus are you drew a red card.
So it's minus one,
but then you move on to a deck
that has one less red card
and that's it.
You either decide to stop or
if you've decided to draw a,
you know what the chances
of getting a black card are.
You look at the black cards, 26
out of, you know, if I'm, I'm,
I'm down there,
it's 21 out of 47 sounds horrible.
21 out of 47 I win a dollar.
26 out of 47 I lose a dollar.
So the immediate draw is terrible.
But if I get a black card,
I moved to this situation and if I get
a red card, I moved to this situation.
Okay. So that's clearly, okay.
So do you agree with me that that's
what the value is going to be?
And so if you look at,
okay, so now, okay, is there any
questions? This is a critical formula.
How critical spot does everyone,
it's Sophia be here now in trouble.
Somebody came and said hello to me
after class and now I know her name.
So just this formula makes sense.
Yeah.
Kathleen? Yes. Is it Katherine
or Kathleen? Catherine. Okay.
Catherine, you, you, so you agree
with this formula, right? Okay.
But this formula is the
key is just like our tree.
Once you know what the
values are down here,
you can always go backwards and
figure out the value here. Okay. So,
um, uh, you know,
so what is the tree the tree's going to
have? Well, I'm going to draw it on a,
I'll do it on a computer.
So now he can just do the sonic computer.
MMM.
I hope I don't have to do that.
Okay, so you have this
by the way, and your, uh,
it's on the web.
Oh No.
Why are all these, okay, the red
question mark. Okay, so here it is.
So you can see that on,
on this.
I can do it with this on this thing.
It's, by the way, this was, uh, uh,
I did my own spreadsheet
and an undergraduate last
year thought it was so messy
that a, she just, we did it
for me. So this is her doing,
it looks much better than I did. So
anyway, here are the number of cards.
This is what the number
of black cards left.
This is the number of red cards left.
And the, and then when you go to the,
you know, the corresponding
coordinate like this one,
this is the value of the game.
When you have one black card
and one red card, it's a fee.
Even though there's an even deck, it's
a favorable gain to you. Why is that?
Because you draw the first card. If it's
black, which happens with probability,
50% you win a dollar. So you've
got half a dollar. If it's red,
which happens with a 50% probability,
you can draw the next one.
And so you end up with zero. And by the
way, if he got a black the first time,
obviously you stop.
So you get 50% chance of a dollar and
stopping or 50% chance of going to the end
and getting nothing. So it's value 50%
but that's a bad way of that number.
She's got a much better way
of calculating it. Okay?
So what she said is if this is
the, uh, if you had, you know,
no red cards and only black cards,
the value is to go to the end of the
deck and just win them all. Okay.
So if you've got only red cards in the
deck and the top line is no black cards,
obviously you should quit right away.
So we've got this first
thing trivially done.
Now how do you figure out this thing?
Well, if you look at the formula up there,
it's just the formula you
wrote, okay? We wrote,
which is you could quit if he wanted to.
So you have to take the Max of zero.
But if you go on and draw,
I can't read what's written there.
If you go on and draw, there's
is going to be, you know,
the probability of red,
okay?
This is the probability of getting a
read over the total number of cards.
Times losing a dollar,
okay?
Plus what happens is you then move.
If you do red,
then you go to,
um
Oh,
what did she do?
C four we're almost seeing forest
here, okay? Right? So, sorry,
I was getting confused with the car.
And so c four is this squared. Okay?
That's the value in here.
So see forces,
if you draw a red card the first time
it happens with this probability,
the number of reds over
the total number of cards,
you lose a dollar and then you move to
the position c four which is one back
here, the one where you've got one less
red card and just the black card left.
Okay. On the other hand, you could have
drawn the first time, not the red one,
but the black one. Okay. Divided
by the total number of cards.
And he would have won a dollar,
but then you would have
moved to the position where
you had one last black card,
which is d three which is up here. Okay?
So instead of doing the whole game,
she says half the time you win
and are half the time you win.
But then you move over to
here and get that value.
Half the time you lose and
then you lose a dollar.
And when you move over to here.
So she's done that.
That same formula appears in every box.
So all you had to do with just copy it,
you know it's Max's and euro.
And then the chance that
you're going to lose a dollar,
which is the number here
of red over the total,
it's times minus a dollar
and then moving over to here.
Or You could get the probability of
winning a dollar with the black cards and
then, but then you would end up
see when a dollar and then even,
but then you move up to here.
Okay,
so it's very simple now the, okay, so, so,
okay, so she's done it and notice that
all of Overdeck is even at one party each.
So it sounds like a fair game.
It's not.
It's a favorable game because you have
an option. So you all understood that.
But the thing is the option is
much more valuable than you think.
So let's see what the value of a game is.
Okay?
It's when you had 26 black
cards and 26 red cards.
We have to go way over here.
Here.
Sorry.
Where am I going?
Not the right answer.
Okay,
here it is.
26 26 the value of the game is
$2.60 not just half a dollar.
You wanted to quit wherever
you are at half a dollar.
It's not looking up anymore.
So you want,
so you wanted to quit with a hat. You
don't have to the first draw, okay?
But it's much better than that.
So now what the shocking
thing though is so poll.
So this means with 26, 26 you can, you
have a favorable gaming, you should draw.
If you didn't draw it, be worth zero. So
obviously you're supposed to draw here.
If you get a black card, you're going
to go here. So hearing your down,
you've gotten a card and you've
got one more. Uh, you know,
it wasn't that likely you're going to
get black. But if you did 50% chance,
you go here. So you win a dollar and
now you're at this position. Now,
if you were supposed to stop,
you would have a,
if you're supposed to stop at that point,
what would you have done?
If you're supposed to stop at that point,
you would have had value zero.
So the fact that that number
is positive is telling you,
even when the deck is against you,
25 you can't see it.
It's 25 blacks and only and still 26 reds.
It's still a favorable game.
You should draw a card and if by
some miracle you want a dollar,
you would have moved to here.
So now you're 26 red in 24 black,
but the game is still
favorable. You should draw
another dollar. Another, sorry,
another card. Okay. And if you win again,
you're here. Now you've gone one, two,
three times.
You've drawn blacks and you should still
draw another one four times getting
blacks.
You should still draw another one,
five consecutive black draws the card.
The deck is now 26 against
you and 21 in your favor.
You should draw again, the game is
still slightly favorable. And uh,
it just seems shocking.
That could be the case,
but this is the proof that it's the case.
So anyway,
that illustrates the power of the option
of being able to continue. And if we,
and if you work,
you're going to work out low numbers
two and three in the homework,
and then you'll see very clearly why it
is that this option is just so powerful.
It's uncannily strong. So there
are any questions about this? Yes.
Um,
I'm still a little bit confused.
I didn't know that the ocean by those
probabilities guys pretty is a little bit
against you, especially
when you, after five weeks,
why do one another?
Yes.
The option by that is a little bit
about it. Let's do it again. Yeah.
This isn't the option value and
this is the value of plain. Okay.
So it says the option value is bigger
than the more important than the fact that
the cards are against you.
So he's asking,
my ta is asking
how could it possibly be that the deck
is now 26 red in 21 black totally against
you. And according to this
calculation, you should still draw.
He can't see the advantage in drawing
because the odds are pretty high.
You're going to get a red card
time. Okay, well that's true.
You're going to get a red card next time.
But the thing is,
your downside is limited. You can never,
here's a way of thinking about it.
You can never,
you're up five cards.
You can never lose more than $5 from
that point on because you can always play
to the end of the deck,
right? Which means you, you,
you lose the five back that you
already won. So there's a downside.
The downside of losing is
limited. Here. On the other hand,
there's a big upside to you. You
might by some miracle draw, um,
10 consecutive black ones at that
point, and then you could quit. Okay?
And then you'd have a big, so your upside
is much bigger than your downside. Now,
the upsides less probable than the
downside. So it's not so obvious,
which is going to be bigger.
Is the option value more important or
is the fact that the deck is against you
more important? It would be
impossible to intuit the answer,
but we don't have to intuit it.
We just proved it.
We've solved for the optimal strategy.
Are there any other questions? It's
quite amazing, right? This, uh,
okay.
I'm going to pause for a second.
Yes.
Okay. That's what we just
did. So let's try it again.
Okay.
So what we did this,
number V is the expected profit you're
going to make if you start with B black
cards and our red cards.
And now the intuitive mind figures
that if B is less than our,
you've got an unfavorable deck
and you should just quit. Okay?
But that's not the case.
You can figure out what the profit is,
how by doing backward induction,
you couldn't tell what the value of this
bond is here with all these defaults
and stuff until you started computing
backwards till you got to here.
So the same way here,
we know at the edges it's very obvious
when all the cards are black or all the
cards or, or a red that's up here.
It's obvious what the value is.
But if you have a position here,
you can figure out what the value is of
being in that position of one and one.
You could quit and be zero.
Or You could say,
what am I chances of getting a black card
and winning a dollar if I get a black
card,
then I moved to this position,
but I already figured out this
position's value cause I'm doing backward
induction. Right? That's got one less,
um, sorry. If I draw a black card,
I go this way, it's got one less black
card and we already know that valley,
that position is zero. So to figure
out the value of this position,
I know the chance of getting a black card.
Then I'm going to end up in that
position, which is value zero. Okay,
I won't draw anymore or I'm going to get
a red card and then I'm going to move
to this position over here. Who's
value I've already computed. Okay,
so that gives me the value here.
How do I figure out the value here?
Well it's now two reds and one black,
so this looks really bad.
Actually, this position, the value of
this I happen to know is zero. Okay?
How could it be with two red
cards and only one black card?
Actually the value of the position
is zero. Well, what do I do?
The chances of getting a black card
the first time or a third. So via one,
two is going to be a third.
Okay.
I'm getting a black card
plus then I go to here,
which is no black cards left
and just red cards. Okay.
Which obviously is zero plus two thirds.
Okay.
Two thirds of the time I get
a red card and lose a dollar.
But then I'm going to move to here with
one red card where I have v of one and
one which I've already figured
out the answer to. Right.
This was v of one and one
has value a half. Okay.
So therefore we have one and two is going
to be two thirds times minus one plus
v of one to write. I just drew
a black card. So it's no longer,
no, I drew a red card,
so it's one and one.
So I started with one black and two reds.
A third of the time I get a black card.
Two thirds of the Times I get a red card.
But after getting the red card,
the position is now one black and
one red or red card disappeared.
That's over here. Okay, so you
get a black card. I moved to here.
We know what if I get a red card,
I moved to there.
But v of one lawn is worth a half.
So that's equal to one third times one
plus zero plus two thirds imes minus one
plus a half.
Okay?
Which equals one third minus one third,
which equals zero.
Okay?
So starting at this point,
you've got one red card and two black
cards. It looks horrible to pick a card.
Two thirds of the time you're
going to get the wrong card,
but you're still have a position that's
actually equal in value because if you
get that a black card, which wins,
you stop. If you get a red card,
you're now in a position that's equal
deck and the deck is fee that's favorable
for you because if you get
another black card, you stop.
And if you get a red card, you keep
playing until the end. Okay? So, um,
uh, okay. So that's it. So how can
you do this by backward induction?
You have the stuff on
the edges and then you,
you solve for all these things along
the side here. And having done that,
now I can solve for this one cause I've
got up into the left and I do that whole
row.
Then I can do this whole row and then I
can just do I back introduction to the
whole, you know, the whole thing.
And the computer does that instantly.
So it figures out the value of every
single node and it's shocking with the
answer is so there any
other questions about this?
Hm,
Ben, you, so I,
I tell you initially taking
care about it as well. I imagine
you stay till the end for,
you could choose to play in this game
and after your wing are you living,
then you'll
get the option that's continue with
the game as a separate that option.
Well that is your option. The option is
always to keep playing or to stop. Okay.
So let's, let's just do, and
with the value I wrote down,
is the value of the game to you of being
able to play the whole game however you
want. Okay, so now let's do the,
let's do another example.
Yes.
Right?
So if you got it,
is that,
my question is,
is it preference to risk or is
it actually the rationality?
Right. So this is going to
become very important very
shortly. So his question is,
I just proved, you know, if you
can call that approved by computer,
the computer proved that even
if you got five blacks in a row,
you should still draw another card.
Of course things are quite
risky now because you know
there's a very good chance
you're going to lose
on that very next card.
So he's saying if you're risk averse,
maybe you would stop there.
And how can you distinguish somebody
who's risk averse from someone who's just
dumb and can't make the calculation?
So we have to,
so that's going to be a question we're
going to take up in the very next class.
But I would say that it's usually because
people are dumb and can't make the
calculation.
So they just don't realize how valuable,
how favorable the situation is they're
in by having this option to be able to
play to the end of it, to stop
when they want to stop. Okay.
So let's just do one more example.
Suppose that you,
um,
suppose that you are undergraduates
and you want to get married.
You've been told that's
a good idea and you,
it's going to be very a sexist thing.
But anyways, also a game I invented,
which turned out not to be
okay.
As original as I thought. Uh, so I
call this the optimal marriage problem.
So,
okay.
So let's say you knew you were going to
meet a thousand women. You're taking,
telling him from the guy's point of view,
okay,
you're going to meet a thousand women.
Okay.
1,000 women and each woman
you meet her suitability.
You can't tell until you meet her and
talk to her. And after you meet her, uh,
each woman's suitability,
each suitability
is he uniform lead distributed
on zero one. Okay. So what do I mean by
that? I mean you meet or you talk to her,
you get to know her and then you
just draw, you know, and so when you,
before you met her,
you have no idea how suitable she's
going to be after you've talked to her,
you understand how suitable the best is.
It's one the worst at zero.
And it could be a draw anywhere between
zero and one before you meet her.
You have no idea.
After you meet her,
you know exactly suitable
she is and they're going to
be a thousand of them that
you're going to meet.
You couldn't meet.
Like the problem is that after you've
talked to him and you can marry her then,
or if you move on
or you can move on, but once you've
moved on, you can never go back to her.
So the question is, um, so
you understand the problem.
The problem is that let's say the first
woman is 0.95 or 0.9. Oh you think,
Gosh, how suitable this is
a great match. But you know,
I've got 999 more women to go.
Maybe I'll do better.
And then you get Zeros from then on.
And so you've missed your 0.9
and so you're not going to,
you're going to end up marrying the
last one who's maybe a zero for you.
That doesn't mean she's a
zero just for you. A zero. So
I trying anyways.
Okay,
so what should your optimal strategy be
and are you playing the optimal strategy?
So what do you think? You know, just
intuitively, what's the optimal strategy?
Of course we're going to do
it by backward induction,
but what do you think it's going to
look like? The optimal strategy. Yes.
Yeah.
Right. That is the actual,
that's what's going to happen.
We're going to prove this, but
he's, he's exactly picked, he said,
you set a threshold here at the beginning.
You know,
you'll marry her if
she's above some number.
You keep to that threshold for a while
and you haven't married anyone. You'd say,
Oh my God, I'm running out of women. And
then you're in standards just collapse.
Okay. So it's best for
patients. That's it.
Okay.
So that's absolutely right.
But the only interesting
thing is to figure out how
high the standard should be.
So how high do you think
it is at the beginning?
Okay,
what would you say the
number is at the beginning?
Okay.
Okay. Now let me give you a
hint. Uh, if you divide up.
Okay, so there's, here's one
and there's a thousand women.
So here's zero, okay? So
they're randomly picked.
So if you could look at all the women
and see and pick out the most suitable
one, what would her suitability
be? Well, her suitability would be,
um,
her suitability.
So top the top on average will
be something like a thousand,
over 1,001. Okay? This
is a famous problem.
If you take and people randomly,
uh, you know, you take any numbers,
you pick random when
uniformly in zero one,
the top one on average is going to be,
if there's a thousand women,
it's a thousand over a thousand.
One second top,
he's going to be 999 over 1,001.
So this very standard statistical
result actually was derived by a,
by a former professor and World War II.
The Americans captured German tanks,
which had all their serial
numbers on them. And uh, you know,
they see the first tank was number one,
the second tank was number two.
The third tank they made was number three.
So we captured a bunch of them.
And then we had to guess how many
tanks did they make. Anyhow, so the,
so it's related to this,
uh,
to this idea that if the
uniformly distributed on
zero one the top one's going
to be on average a thousand or
1,001, nine 99 or 1001, et cetera.
But now you've seen, so, okay, so where,
what standard would you set
for the first one? Right?
You have to set some threshold
here. You know, here's one,
and here's zero. By the end
you'll take any, you know,
but the last woman you've got, you're
going to take her no matter what. So what,
uh, what should the threshold
be? Well, it's hard to tell.
We can't do it except by backward
induction. So what would you guess?
Awesome.
One we're then you'll
never take or if it's one,
because the odds of getting exactly
one r zero. So what would you guess?
Huh?
So you'd set the threshold this high,
a thousand over 1,001.
Okay. So that means you're
expecting to get as good a woman is.
If you could go to the very
end and look at all of them,
you never make a mistake. I told you
there's a chance you'll make a mistake.
The first one's the best.
It doesn't quite come to your threshold
and all the rest of their worst.
Then you end up with a disaster here. So
you know you, you, you, you know, so you,
you have a chance of not
doing that once your,
you're setting to highest standard here
cause you have a very good chance of
saying no to all these women and then
ending up with what's you right. Okay.
However you're on the right track.
So amazingly,
this is the answer. This
is the threshold. Okay?
So you should set the threshold at where
you expect the second highest woman to
be second highest match to be.
And that is why there's so many
novels about the other woman.
Because if you're playing optimally,
you should be ending up with the second
best woman and there should be one other
woman that at the end of your life you
regret that you didn't wait for and,
but only one other
woman. So anyway, I just,
I just want to prove this to you in
the same way we proved it before,
just by solving for backward
induction for the optimal.
So we can just do this by
backward induction. We know
exactly what to do. Okay?
So I, you know, it's one thing
to say what you should do.
It's another thing to prove.
That's what you should do.
And I'm going to prove it now. So you
can just see by backward induction how,
how easy it is to do these things.
Okay. So it's only, you know,
I'm going to have to take four minutes.
If you can hang out for four minutes,
we'll get this.
So what happens with two women left?
What's v of to
what should you do?
What should your threshold be for two,
what is your threshold be?
For two women. So here's the
threshold and we have two and three.
Okay?
So I'll tell you threshold for one
threshold for one woman is zero.
If it's the last woman there, you know,
you w w whatever she is, she's, you know,
it's,
that's it.
You're going to might as well marry or
it's only going to can't be negative.
Okay?
And then the value
I'm carotid is the value of one
is going to be a half, right?
Because if there's one woman left,
you're going to take her no matter what.
And on average you'll get a half.
So the question is now,
what's the threshold when they're two
women left and what's your expected
payoffs? So what's the threshold
if they're two women left,
you'll see the second to last woman,
you talk to her,
you find out how good the matches you
should take her if she's above the matches
above what? No, there was
only one woman left after her.
So
good.
So I have right,
because if you don't take her,
you're going to go to the last woman
on average, you're going to get a half.
So there's no point in taking someone
who's match is less than a half.
When the break, next step, you are an
average, you're going to get a half.
So your threshold is a half. So what's
your expected quality of the match? Well,
with probability a half you get,
you make you with probability a half,
she's going to be above a half.
And if she's above a half, she's going
to be halfway between one and a half.
So it's three quarters. And
with probability, uh, sorry,
this end with probability a half,
she's going to be below a half and
you're going to pass on her and go to the
last one and it'll be on average a half.
Okay,
so this is three A's loss. Um, no,
probably the half. She's going to be
three quarters and probability a half,
she'll be a half. So three A's was
one quarter is five eighths. Okay.
Now what if there were three women,
what should the threshold be for three
women and what's the value of three?
Okay, so the threshold should be v
of two, which is five eighths. Okay.
And what's the value?
The value is going to be,
what's the chance that you take
the one you just meet? Well,
the odds that she's above a
half is three A's. So it's three
times the average of one and you know,
halfway between.
So she's above five days. So she's
somewhere between one in five days.
So that's going to be a one plus five
days over to Kate plus five ace of the
time you pass on her and
then you get five A's.
So that equals if we just do that in a
little bit more generally it's one minus
V two.
Okay.
So that's one minus v two times one
Plus v two divided by two plus V of two
times.
Um,
we have to,
okay, so that's what the pro,
that's the formula. So for any,
so in general v of t hey,
you set the threshold at v of t minus one.
So with probability V of t minus one
you're going to get one plus v of t minus
one divided by two and
with probability one minus,
um no.
This is one minus V of t minus one with
probability V of t minus one you're
going to get, you're going to pass
on her and go to the next thing.
So you get just v of t minus one.
Okay? So that's just a formula.
V of t equals some function
of v of t minus one.
So you can program that into a computer,
which is ending.
Now with this one picture, that's the
end of it. Sorry, I know I've gone over,
but this is the last picture and only
take a second. So zero yield curve.
Optimal marriage. Okay, so here it is.
Here's with one woman your
your value. Oh Shit. Sorry.
With one woman,
the value is a half one match to go.
Okay? So the number on the
left is with one match to go.
The valley's a half with two.
It's five days with three.
We computed that too. So you can
tell for however many women you want.
Now what I've done on the right
number is this, and plus one over.
It's an over n plus n minus
one of rent plus one. Okay?
So that's the second best woman.
How how good she'd be on average for you.
And as you go down further and further,
you see these numbers are getting
to be the same. So this number,
this number is practically the same.
And if you go down to the very bottom,
you'll see they're identical,
okay?
Up to an incredible number of decimal
places. You get the, the, the,
these two numbers are the same.
So if there are enough women,
you're going to hear,
get exactly the second best,
and it's going to be the problem
with the other one. But anyway,
the point of all this was to just
illustrate how powerful the option is.
It's as if you could go to the very
end and pick out the second best one,
even though you have to
do them sequentially.